let's talk first of all about this
stalling as we're hearing about of the
the Russia offensive around uh back mode
what are the key points there the main
point is that this uh Russian offensive
has been going since January and they've
thrown an awful lot at it but what
Russia seems to be doing now the Russian
the UK mod has deployed it looks like
the Russians are redeploying their
forces well they call euphemistically to
stabilize the front line in effect it
means in the defense they're looking as
if they're doing up to the north of
criminal down to the South there abdica
just next to you there all the way up to
uh to back moot
um now it's worth remembering that the
Russian offensive was really started
earlier than they probably would have
wanted to the weather is bad Etc they
threw probably though it's out of fear
and anticipation of the Ukraine spring
offensive Western tanks and everything
on their way
um they threw 300 000 inexperienced
soldiers at the fight wave after wave in
a sort of 20th century form of Highly
attritional Warfare they're taking huge
casualties they've stalled and by any
metric the Russians have made very very
limited progress and so now it's an
opportunity to just pause consolidate
the gains they've made and prepare for
whatever may come in the spring and I
mean a couple of weeks ago we were
saying quite often or Batman's going to
fall within a matter of days or or a
week at least why didn't that ultimately
happen we talked so much about seven
months we've been talking about macmost
I mean for a much perspective it's not a
significant attack but it's become
incredibly symbolic with Russia
particularly President Putin wanting to
win now at the moment the Russians have
got to the east of the bahamuta river
the ukrainians have got to the West
there's a route just by your hips there
which is the 504 access route and the
pincers were coming around to try and
cut off Ukraine and resupply but the
reason it's not full I think there's
three main reasons one of which is this
is urban Warfare fighting in a built-up
area it massively favors the defense and
you generally have three times as many
casualties on the offense
and that's when you use experienced War
Fighters the Russians have been using
very inexperienced cannon fodder they've
lost seven to one casualty rates so 30
000 soldiers bile accounts have been
lost in this one city alone second
reason the Wagner group were part of the
lead for this they were under yeah and
they were making some progress but as
they made progress Evgeni became quite
critical of the Russian army but also
about Putin in an effort to try and
manage that Putin stopped him recruiting
from the prisons and also stopped him
having access to ammunition and Valerie
garozzimov took over Russian army they
also didn't want him claiming credit for
seizing back moot the job is when the
Army took over it all stalled again so
The Clash of egos going on here Russian
egos has thoroughly compromised and
distracted away from Main effort and the
third reason that back moot's not
foreign is an absolutely heroic
Ukrainian defense the city has been
devastated even the U.S both military
and political were suggesting sizzling
you need to withdraw your experienced
Fighters out ready for the battles to
come zelensky did the opposite he
reinforced the city and that seems to
have worked at least for now so uh
stepping about bigger picture Sean for
the the weeks ahead for the entire War
what are you focused on well the Russian
offensive has failed um huge councilor
he's lost a load of Tanks as well and
it's going to take a while to regroup
they've now got 1200 kilometers of front
line and even if you spread out Russian
soldiers 200 000 of them across evenly
it's only one every six meters the sort
of width of this studio that's not
strength in debt so they have to work
out where Ukraine is going to attack
when they're going to attack and how
they're going to attack and the main
thing there I think there's three main
areas from a military analyst one will
be if you remember that yellow areas
where the ukrainians very successfully
mastered account if they pushed uh there
the second one is around Bak moot to
actually start to take back some of the
ground there and the third area is in
this Corridor here obviously the water
acts as a barrier but from zapparicha
all the way across to the Donetsk region
if they were to sever the land bridge
there that would be uh the other reason
but regardless of how successful any
spring offensive would be it will run
out of steam eventually because
Logistics limits it and by the end of
the summer most analysts believe that
this whole conflict will have ground to
a bit of a hole the front line may have
moved a bit but that's when
International pressure will ramp up to
try to find some way of getting a
ceasefire and find some way of evolving
how you bring peace and bring this water
to a close